MICHAEL HODIN: We
would like to welcome everyone to today's
meeting; delighted to have you here.
I'm Mike Hodin, adjunct senior fellow at the
Council on Foreign Relations, running a studies
program on aging populations.
Kelly Michel, senior executive at AEGON Corporation,
a global insurance firm.
Many of you here in America know it as Transamerica.
AEGON is a global company based out of The
Hague in The Netherlands.
And Dr. Joe Coughlin, founder and head of
MIT AgeLab.
You have the bios in your materials, so we
won't spend much time on that.
Today's meeting is co-sponsored by the Washington
meetings program and the studies program at
CFR.
It is on the record.
But before I go much further, I did want to
give you an explanation of why there are only
three of us on the podium here, and not the
fourth, Undersecretary Bob Hormats.
For those of you who did not read your emails
that you got, it was either yesterday -- I
guess it was yesterday -- which was a reminder
that indicated that at the last minute, unfortunately,
the undersecretary, due to another commitment
-- actually, a couple of blocks from here
-- is unable to join us.
So we do apologize for that.
But I can assure you that it was a responsibility,
and we within CFR understand that these things
happen, particularly with someone like the
undersecretary who, obviously, has these senior
political responsibilities.
But I did want to open by turning your attention
to a post that the undersecretary did which
appeared yesterday afternoon in the Huffington
Post to, not least, indicate his interest
in this topic and command of its framing,
titled "Aging Population, Economic Growth
and Global Competitiveness," a reference to
this meeting here today -- which, by the way,
is on the record.
And it's about the U.S. aging population as
an economic growth driver for global competitiveness.
And a couple of the references that the undersecretary
makes: It is vital that we create opportunities
to enable older persons to contribute to their
economies and communities in increasingly
effective and productive ways.
This will require new policies and innovations,
and promote healthy aging.
And then he goes on to say: Providing opportunities
for continued contribution by an aging population
is an economic imperative in a growing number
of countries, both developed and developing,
including, of course, the United States.
And then, toward the conclusion: We need a
focused, societywide effort to transform our
vision of aging from a time of dependency
to a time of continued growth, contribution
and social and economic participation.
So I think that really sets the framework
for us.
So let me give you a couple of other points
of introduction, and then we'll immediately
go to our discussion, which we will undertake
for about 20 or 25 minutes among us here,
and then open it up for the second 30 minutes
for audience participation and questions and/or
comments.
As indicated, this is a somewhat unusual event
in Council on Foreign Relations framework.
It is a collaboration between the studies
program, which has our aging populations framework
undertaking reports and studies and round
tables and meetings of this kind; but then
also, CFR broadly has a program celebrating
its 90th anniversary this year, from last
September to September of 2012.
And the framework for that is renewing America
and America's strength in the world, America's
competitiveness.
Many of us think of that topic as related
to pure economic and fiscal policy, perhaps
military policy.
What we're here to discuss today is the relationship
that that has to our aging populations.
In this 21st century, our new demographic
reality is such that America and all of our
G-20 partners, and a growing number of countries
around the world, including developing countries,
align to trends of urbanization, globalization;
have populations where there are more people
over 50, 55, than under that in working age.
This will be a growing trend during the course
of the next several decades.
And in a word, the idea that we can remain
competitiveness -- remain competitive, the
idea that we could maintain fiscal sustainability,
not to speak of looking for economic growth,
in an environment where this aging population
demographic reality has shifted, is something
we want to bring to our discussions around
public policy generally, and foreign policy
in particular.
So perhaps we can open up, and I wanted to
just -- I have a few suggested questions that
we might at least start the conversation.
Joe, perhaps you could give us an opening
by reviewing some of the data, the demographics
of where we are in America, where some of
the other countries, our competitors, are,
and where we stand in that context.
>>JOSEPH COUGHLIN: Sure.
You know, it's very interesting that aging
has been quite often -- I would say it has
been dominantly told as a story of concern.
When was the last time any of us felt that
living longer was a problem?
We should be declaring -- giving ourselves
an applause for getting the ability to live
longer.
Essentially, what we're looking at is two
converging forces: a(n) increase in longevity,
where life expectancy at the year 1900 was
somewhere about 45, 47 years old -- 45 probably
in the United States; 47 roughly in Europe
-- to today, if you look at some statistics,
is well into your 70s.
But interestingly enough, the fastest-growing
part of the population is 85-plus.
By the way, within that cohort is 100-plus.
So, yes, we are living longer.
And essentially, if you can get kids to live
past 5 years old, or past 10 years old, you
get to live probably a pretty good, long,
healthy life in general, or at least manage
well.
That's one part of the story.
The other part of the story is -- is that,
as income and education goes up, fertility
tends to go very far down.
So we're looking at countries in Europe, for
instance, that have a fertility rate of 1.7,
1.8 children per female.
You need 2.1 just to keep the population even.
The United States with immigration like -- is
at about 2.1.
We are the few (sic), and some would even
argue the only, industrialized country still
growing.
So anecdotally, what do these numbers mean?
Well, let's -- you can see a lot by looking,
as the great philosopher Yogi Berra said.
There are now more wheelchairs and walkers
in places like Italy, Germany and France,
than there are, say, baby carriages.
In the United States -- we'll do a test here.
How many of you were born between 1946 and
'64?
These are the Baby Boomers.
The people who don't have their hands up are
younger, wish you'd just be quiet; and the
older folks would wish you'd just go away.
(Laughter.)
One of us is turning 66 -- one every seven
or eight seconds.
And is this just an industrialized world phenomenon?
Absolutely not.
The one child, one family policy of China
has had a demographic destiny of where there's
165 million people over age 60 there.
And by the way, as we're looking at nations,
as we're looking at regions, we must look
within nations as well.
The average farmer in Indonesia -- one of
the most populous countries in the world,
and indeed one of the youngest -- but now
the average farmer is 47.
So it's not just a matter of looking at a
region, looking at a nation; we have to look
at industries, we have to look at specific
regions, and we have to plan to make aging
an opportunity not just to live longer, but
to live better.
>>HODIN: Thank you.
Great, great contextual start.
So Kelly, as one thinks of this topic of aging
populations, many people automatically go
to the policies and innovations around health.
And we'll get to that, and that's clear.
But there are other topics as well, and one,
of course, is critical around financial policy,
financial security.
Perhaps you can give us some sense of where
the innovative thinking in that is.
>>KELLY MICHEL: Thank you.
First, let me start off by saying thank you
for having me on the panel.
And I'm honored to be here for the 90th anniversary.
The center has expand -- or has exceeded the
actuarial tables of most organizations, or
at least people's life spans -- (laughter)
-- so that's always the good news.
We can all aspire to be 90.
Particularly relevant to our topic today.
It is a really exciting time to be in our
business, which is the business of protecting
people's futures with lots of type of financial
instruments.
And the things that we're talking about today
in the United States are topical around the
entire country.
Our focus today is -- and there's a lot of
discussion today about the idea of longevity
and living longer and trying to create products
that help people feel secure about their longevity
or their -- you know, like to your earlier
point, like, is it a bad thing that we're
actually going to live to 85 or beyond that?
I mean, this is the debate that we're having.
And in the financial services market, of course,
we're trying to find solutions to help people
feel good about those things.
I think the debates that we see today with
respect to entitlement reform and all that
is a lot around people's insecurity around
what's going to happen in that future.
And so it's incumbent upon our business market
to think through ways to help provide that
type of security through programs that are
available from the early parts of an individual's
life, so that it's not something that they
start to think about when, arguably, we might
think it's too late to start thinking about
it or if there's not enough time.
So we're challenged on a global basis, and
it's important to kind of take the lessons
that we learn in one market and transfer them
into the opportunity that it might create
in another market.
So if you look at the European marketplace
and their philosophy around living and social
networks that provide for things that may
not necessarily, let's say, be available in
the United States, it's important to try to
look at that and look for opportunities where
we can learn, but, more importantly, where
we can look for opportunities to enhance the
life of our folks here in the United States
specifically, for my particular interest,
but more importantly, that we look for products
that can augment or forgo what may have happened
poorly in another marketplace.
So we're spending a tremendous amount of time
trying to look for opportunities there.
>>HODIN: So -- thank you.
So speaking of Europe, as many of us will
know, 2012 -- Europe has announced that it
is the year of healthy and active aging, not
least, as Joe mentioned, because of this proportion
they now have to deal with of work/retirement,
if one looks at retirement in the traditional
sense of over 60.
I look around the room.
Several of us came back from the first APEC
meeting in 2012, held in Moscow.
It was cold.
But APEC now has a strategy on active aging,
huge interest throughout particularly the
Asian region.
We know that those dependency ratios in Taiwan,
China, Singapore, are going to be reaching
40 percent within the next couple decades.
It's not surprising, then, that the World
Health Organization has declared that 2012,
its World Health Day will be dedicated to
aging populations.
So 2012 has sort of emerged as a year where
we look at this topic of aging populations,
and inside that, as we look here in the council
at what does it mean for America and our competitiveness
and of foreign economic policy, I suppose
my question is, what is America's value proposition
relative our trading partners, relative our
G-20 competitors?
And how can we take some steps that could
model ourselves in a way that perhaps our
European friends or friends in APEC and other
places will look to?
Joe, if you could pick that one up.
>>COUGHLIN: I'm going to give -- identify,
I think, two assets -- one tangible, one less
so, but I will argue that the less tangible
asset is America's greatest source of strategic
advantage.
We did a study with Gallup-Healthways Well-Being
Index to measure the well-being of adults
of any age, but we focused primarily on the
50-plus.
And we looked at the well-being of older Germans,
the well-being of older folks in the U.K.
and, of course, older Americans.
And we found that the Germans were healthier
overall -- chronic disease and much more physically
fit and walked and did all the things we should
do.
The British had better access, in many cases,
to services, like National Health Service
and the like.
And the Americans, you can tell by looking
at me, did not exercise as much.
We thought that cheese steak was a food group.
(Laughter.)
And on objective measures, we were not faring
as well in old age as our German and U.K.
counterparts.
But guess what?
We blew the index off in terms of being in
a far higher state of well-being.
That less tangible asset, that I would argue
is distinctly American -- some may say misguided,
but I'll go with it -- is optimism; that the
older population in the United States had
a far greater sense of optimism that tomorrow
will be better than yesterday, where we will
find a way.
So that optimism -- less tangible -- tied
to something I do think is more tangible,
is that the U.S. has got a very strong base
of universities and industries developing
new technologies -- and technology without
service is just a commodity -- and services
brought together to figure out how to live
longer better: how to stay in your home, how
to be able to remain in the car or the metro
system, how to stay in the workplace longer;
to reinvent not just living longer, but how
to reinvent living entirely.
So I'd say that the U.S. strategic advantage
is essentially at its core of its political
culture: optimism, and that there's always
going to be a silver bullet to somehow make
it better.
>>HODIN: So Kelly, as you look around the
world, working for a major global corporation,
where are some of the countries that do have
a competitive advantage, or disadvantage,
from the standpoint of aging populations,
and particularly since you're developing and
designing financial instruments that are going
to be useful?
You're looking at pension, you're looking
at retirement, you're looking at financial
security.
>>MICHEL: Well, a couple things.
If you think about just the United States
-- and I'll just use Europe as an example
-- the European market is very DB (ph)-focused.
They're very focused around the idea of the
social network.
And while that still exists in the United
States, it's a very different culture, particularly
if you start looking at the younger ages.
We're very defined-contribution oriented,
we're very self-reliant in many ways, and
I think it's all a matter of how you look
at it.
Right now we focus on that lack of -- it's
easy to get very mired in the idea that people
don't have that same pension opportunity or
pension security blanket like the Europeans
look at, and look at that potentially as a
negative.
But I think particularly as you look at the
younger ages, that may ultimately end up being
a significant advantage, in that we are culturally
already gearing ourselves toward this notion
of self-reliance and the need to save for
retirement.
In fact, Jan and I -- Janet Servonce (ph)
from AEGON -- and I were talking a little
bit.
We're conducting a study right now between
the nuances and differences in attitudes between
the U.S. and the EU with respect to retirement.
And one of the things that is -- the questions
that we want to understand is how people feel
about the ability to stay in their homes.
And the folks that were participating in the
EU side of the survey were sort of completely
baffled by the idea of having to potentially
lose their home.
That just doesn't even occur in their lexicon
of concerns.
And their questions were more centered around
the loss of happiness or the loss of self-worth
and what not.
It's a completely different paradigm.
So the degree that -- I suppose it's a matter
of how you're looking at the glass, but the
idea that we're very self-reliant and that
we have this culture of self-reliance in the
U.S., I think, while we look at the shortcomings,
that we're not there yet, we have a lot of
work to do to get people to be financially
secure; the notion that the average man is
actually thinking about that, I think, is
a substantial competitive advantage.
And I think I'd like to add to your comments
the fact that U.S., particularly the entrepreneurship
of the U.S., cannot be underestimated as it
relates to trying to solve this problem, to
bring us to some innovative conclusions.
And, you know, working with government to
try to create that environment, I think will
help us tremendously in the long run.
>>COUGHLIN: Yeah.
Especially if you look at some of the Kauffman
Foundation data, it suggests that the next-generation
entrepreneur is not someone who's 20-something
from MIT or Stanford and Silicon Valley but
rather is more likely to be someone 45 and
older, and more likely to be a woman.
So as I look in the mirror every day and aging
becomes a greater reality --
>>MICHEL: You could be talking about me.
I love that!
(Laughs.)
MR.
: -- I need that entrepreneur.
>>HODIN: Well, as we get very close to opening
up to the full discussion, let's -- our proposition
here is really, in a way, very simple, but
many will look at it as ranging from naive
to idealistic to unrealizable.
And it is simply that in our 21st century,
we've now, over the last century, added roughly
three decades to life.
That's certainly true in America, and it's
true largely around the G-20.
So if we're going to live into our 90s, the
idea of being -- having a work-retirement
structure and public policies aligned to that
-- that was built, by the way, off of the
Bismarck model in the 19th century, and operating
through the 20th century -- how in the world
can that be applicable to the 21st?
Yet, whether we're talking about Wisconsin,
the budget that was just put out yesterday
-- I guess this direction -- or Greece, politics
certainly seems to get in the way.
How do we manage this?
How do we find our way toward a future where
the aging population begins to be understood
as engaging in economic activity, part of
a growth driver?
You know, that's a -- such a huge sociological
and cultural shift that it's almost how do
you get your mind around that?
What is the realism for that?
>>COUGHLIN: How do we get it done?
>>HODIN: Yes.
>>COUGHLIN: At least it's an easy question,
right?
I think -- and this is a conversation that
Mike and I have had offline as well, but I
think we now really need to have a phased
redefinition of our social contract with -- as
individuals, with governments, individuals
with each other and the like.
We cannot use yesterday's policies when life
expectancy was only 45 to 50 to redefine our
future 50 years.
So that means yes, working longer is a new
reality, not just to hedge financial problems,
but frankly, working longer is healthier for
you as well.
But before we just say that's all about the
individual, institutions need to change.
The workplace needs to be redesigned physically
as well as perhaps ideologically at how we
look at older workers, how we look at education.
We need to rethink in terms of what does old
age mean in terms of what your contribution
is going to be.
Is it to families alone?
Is it to yourself?
It is to those around you?
So I think that the real change has got to
be about how to look at that next 30 years
not just as a personal dividend of living
longer, but a dividend that society needs
to also equally benefit from, since it also
invested in it.
>>HODIN: Great.
Kelly?
>>MICHEL: I would add that -- I completely
agree, and I would really add to that that
we have to rethink about how we educate people
in this respect, because I can tell you, 20-some
years I've been working in the financial services
market and thinking about education and walking
into a workplace and talking about retirement.
For many, it's the first time they've ever
had a conversation about saving in their entire
life.
And that's not just the youngest of employees;
that's a lot of the employees.
And so for our fundamental understanding of
how we live to change, how we educate people
about this is going to have to change.
And whose responsibility that is to educate
these people has to change.
And so to the degree that this can be begun
at a much younger age in a different -- in
a way that is not meant to be something that
sits on its own -- it should be integrated
into all of the things that we do -- then
you'll find -- I think that we'll see the
workplace change more so than it -- I just
don't think we can do it with the same sort
of understanding that we have today about
the importance of living longer and how to
sustain yourself through that.
It really has to have a big educational component
to it.
>>COUGHLIN: The near normal, I think, has
-- the new normal has to be reinforced, if
you will, by peer pressure.
You know, it worked when we were teenagers;
it'll work through midlife and older life.
What is it that we expect from each other?
And before, we used to expect retirement -- 55,
60, 62 years old was the normal.
That's not going to be sustainable.
But how do we reinforce it amongst each other?
>>HODIN: Thank you.
So hopefully, we've at least set a little
bit of a context, perhaps gotten the juices
flowing a little bit intellectually.
We'd now like to open it up.
Just raise your hand -- yes -- and we'll call
on you.
There will be a microphone.
You can either direct your questions or just
throw it out there.
And if you want to make a comment, that's
fine too, but do limit it so others have a
chance.
QUESTIONER: Thank you.
I'm Steven Koltai.
I run the Global Entrepreneurship Program
at the State Department.
I have a question about the size of the contingent
liability for pensions and Social Security
payments and how that compares between the
United States, Europe and Japan.
And what I'm especially interested in is not
just the public sector size -- so in other
words, not just the Social Security piece
-- but also the private sector pension liability.
And from an economic competitiveness standpoint,
I'm curious how that compares between the
U.S., Europe and Japan.
>>MICHEL: You mean -- I'm sorry, I just want
to make sure I understand the question.
You want to know how big it is --
QUESTIONER: Yes.
>>MICHEL: -- compared to other countries?
In other words, I want to know whether we
are advantaged or disadvantaged in the U.S.
>>MICHEL: I don't know if I have the exact
statistic -- and I apologize for that; I can
certainly get that for you -- of what the
actual total market is.
But I want to say it's, in aggregate, if you
look at defined contribution and defined benefit,
somewhere upwards around the $4 trillion -- and
I don't know if I can give you an accurate
comparison to another country, but I think
what's -- to the topic, I think what's most
important is the ability for people to rely
on that compared to other countries.
And maybe I'm not getting at the heart of
what you're interested in, but from my perspective,
our -- in the United States, I think the typical
-- outside of your home, the typical total
savings on average is around $72,000 right
now.
And if you look at that as a means to measure
whether you're financially secure or not,
I think it doesn't take someone on a panel
to tell you that that's probably not close
enough to what you are going to probably need.
So to that end, compared to some other countries,
we may be behind.
But I think in large part, there is a tremendous
amount of support toward the -- of course,
the increasing of that pool of dollars, but
doing it in such a way where the individual
is really driving that component, which -- and
depends on how you look at it, whether that's
an advantage or a disadvantage.
I don't know.
Joe, you want to add something to that?
>>COUGHLIN: Yeah, I look at those numbers
in terms of per capita -- you know, how many
legs to their Social Security stool that they
have.
There may be many more supports, for instance,
in a -- in a social welfare state.
But now we're starting to find that both the
trust of the viability of that -- those supports
may be in question.
So I'd lean on that.
>>HODIN: And the only thing I would add to
that is when we look -- when we draw our lines
out the next two and three decades, across
the G-20 countries, and you start getting
upwards of 40 percent dependency ratios in
some countries, the numbers become unsustainable.
I'm also very worried -- there are some very
fine experts in a number of these topics among
all of you out there, so if anyone has a particular
data point or fact that you want to throw
out, please raise your hand on that one.
We're not the experts.
Danley (ph).
QUESTIONER: Donmer Haskul (ph), the Social
Security Administration.
When we look at the comparative weight or
the burden of the aging in the future, some
countries come out very well, and quite unexpectedly:
Sweden, Italy, Poland.
And these are countries which have tied the
retirement age to life expectancy.
It's in the law.
And that makes a tremendous difference when
you're projecting those numbers out 20, 30
years.
Now, the question is going to be a political
question: Will they let the law work and raise
the retirement age to 70, 72, 73?
The Swedish prime minister just said 75, and
it caused a press uproar.
(Laughter.)
So you know, it may be in the law, but will
the political process let it run out?
But it is one way to tackle the burden.
>>HODIN: And notwithstanding the firebombs
in the streets of Paris that we saw when President
Sarkozy made his announcements about a year
and a half ago with respect to the age, he
did make progress on tying it to how long
we live.
Again, whether that will be implemented or
not is another story.
There were -- yes, in the back.
>>COUGHLIN: Perhaps we need to tie it to the
-- most people, when you ask them what old
age is, it's always 15 to 20 years older than
they are.
That's what we should tie retirement to.
(Laughter.)
QUESTIONER: I'm Welbry Lyman (ph) from Ways
and Means.
You talked a bit about the potential, the
consumption potential of an aging American
population, and also mentioned just briefly
the potential for productive -- you know,
extended productive capacity.
Can you describe a bit how that works?
What are the types of jobs that we can be
globally competitive in as an aging population?
And does this prioritize services over manufacturing,
for example?
And if so, what does that do to the sort of
generational mix of jobs?
Do we keep -- does everyone in this audience
basically hold onto their jobs for an extra
10 years, and then the folks underneath have
a new ceiling that they can't reach?
Do we need to do something for them?
>>COUGHLIN: Like most things from House and
Means (sic), that's got about five or six
intertwined questions in there.
(Laughter.)
That -- a great question.
First off, I think it plays to America's strategic
advantage even today, which is we don't manufacture
everything; we tend to manage the more high-quality,
high-craft jobs.
And guess what?
Whether you're talking about BMW or the high-end
product manufacturing of, you know, IT devices
and the like, it tends to be the 45- to 50-plus-year-old
worker who either knows exactly what that
craft is -- so exactly how to, say, get a
dashboard into a very expensive vehicle -- or
how a system should be manufactured in IT.
So, yeah, there may be a bias in services,
but not necessarily.
The 50-plus, whether we like to admit or not
when we are under 50, know what organizations
or companies know.
So there's going to be a bias to high-quality/high-value
product.
With respect to the folks who actually work
for a living -- that is, those who use their
bodies and carry bricks and the like -- we
are seeing great advances, particularly in
Europe, around cobotics and robotics being
able to enable people to stay in the workplace
longer.
And lastly -- and I'll yield to Kelly -- is
the notion that there's this low -- long line
of young people banging on the door for the
job, waiting for you to get of your way -- get
out of the way, is true in some areas, but
in most areas, particularly in high tech,
it is not the case.
We have a tremendous shortage of people in
government service, engineering, air traffic
controls.
If anyone flew here, you should know that
the average air traffic controller is closer
to 60 than they are to 40.
And we don't have anyone taking those jobs.
So we really need to keep folks as long as
possible.
And I guess -- and the last point is that
hopefully none of us will stay in the same
job for 30 or 40 years.
Hopefully we will reinvent institutions and
our own expectations to have three or four
different careers in a 60- to 70-year lifespan
of work.
>>MICHEL: I think the average life insurance
salesman is also in the same situation as
your --
MR.
: Yeah.
>>MICHEL: -- as your -- as your high-tech
person.
But I would add to the comments that you just
made -- were that the -- whether you stay
in -- whether you're in a job that can stay
-- that you can sustain for an extra 10 years
or an extra 15 years has a lot to do with
the institution or the industry that you're
in and their value that they place on the
intellectual capital that you have in that
job.
So I think to your point, if you're a bricklayer,
there's a point where your physical stamina
can't keep up with that job at an older age.
But to the degree that you're in a professional
service then -- and that your employer wants
to retain that intellectual capital, it's
going to be very important to know whether
or not you're going to have to find a new
career or not.
Moreover, I think it's important to see that
those companies or those industries that do
value that intellectual capital keep -- that
-- again, getting back to, like, the need
for the educational reinvestment in our people
-- that industry, you would hope, is going
to continue to invest in their -- in their
employees' educational ability to continue
to be competitive.
>>HODIN: Yes, I would just highlight the point
that there aren't that many -- unfortunately
there aren't that many places that we can
turn to right now to give great best practices.
But the few that exist, there are at least
as many that are in the -- what we might consider
blue-collar versus white-collar arena.
And you mentioned BMW factory workers.
Harley-Davidson is another -- some of you
may have seen some pieces on -- which are
doing very interesting and innovative work.
And when you combine that, as Joe mentioned,
with the technology component, we -- we're
going to have to break down all kinds of assumptions
over the next couple decades.
So, you know, this is as much about a culture
and sociological shift as anything else.
Tom, you had a question.
We'll try to get to everyone.
We'll move it around quickly.
QUESTIONER: Tom Miller, I work -- I head an
-- oh, excuse me -- Tom Miller, I head an
organization called International Executive
Service Corps, which is a nonprofit, and we
have about 11,000 volunteers, most of them
retired.
And my question kind of follows up on what
you were just talking about.
It's a specific question for you, Kelly.
What is -- what is AEGON doing specifically
for older people in terms of integrating or
keeping them in the workforce?
And Joe, it's more -- you know, you talk about
changing the culture, and I'd like to get
-- you know, we've talked to a lot of companies,
and it's hard to get them to think that people
over 65 can still contribute to the workforce.
And once you get to that, they say, well,
then we keep people younger from advancing.
And so, Mike, I'd like you to maybe deal with
that.
And our colleague from the State Department
-- I was at the State Department for 30 years,
and we used to have these questions there.
And you know, you always got hung up with,
well, you know, you would really destroy morale
and a lot (other ?) things if you kind of
kept people over a certain age.
>>HODIN (?): Well, just on the last point,
to jump in, I mean, the example that I always
like to use is the women's movement.
I mean, there was a time -- some of us can
remember -- at the beginning of the women's
movement when it was assumed that that was
awful because it would take -- you know, in
those days, I was younger, but -- my job.
Wasn't true.
If -- you know, it's basically the point if
you have a growing economy, if you can look
at growth and opportunity, then you've got
an expanding pie.
If you do have a pie that you're, you know,
cutting up among -- and it's limited, then
you're going to have beggar thy neighbor.
But that's not the place that America has
been, and that's not the place that America
has to be.
>>COUGHLIN (?): (I think ?) also there's bureaucratic
realities.
Corporations are -- have split personalities,
much like government agencies do.
So while you're asking for early outs for
your 55-plus or even 60-year-olds that go
out the door, the head of human resources
and the chief financial officer are all throwing
a party.
They've checked that box.
They've costed -- they've downsized, and they've
saved money.
The technology officer or the chief of product
development and the like is going, if I only
knew what we know.
And by the way, the person who just walked
out took with her the relationship with our
client or took with him how we actually deliver
a given set of services.
And so there's a split personality in there
in terms of how organizations want some people
to get out quickly, so we can bring in new
talent.
On the other hand, we also know that the folks
that sit, you know -- in their heads and in
their drawers are the things that power and
knowledge is made of.
>>MICHEL: I agree with that, and I'll just
make one final comment.
You had asked about AEGON.
AEGON is a -- has a tremendous program to
keep and reinvest in their own staff.
But I think more importantly the comments
that I would make about this topic are relative
to the clients and the organizations that
we serve -- are -- which are everything from
very small, micro-sized employers to very
large employers.
And by and large, these are -- of course,
to your point of sort of organizational sort
of reality that employees sort of come and
go, and it may be lots of reasons why they
may do that -- but most companies don't make
decisions about to keep somebody or to let
someone go based strictly on age.
It could -- there's all sorts of factors around
that.
And I think, again, going back to reinventing
or reinvesting in those people as products
and innovation changes, that comes oftentimes
not just by young people, it comes with a
lot of experience and thoughtfulness around
how the marketplace actually works.
So the loss of intellectual capital at -- for
our older employees is -- it will be just
that, in fact, a really huge loss.
>>HODIN: And one of the components that we
haven't talked about that -- just so -- to
throw out -- the -- being realistic, there
is -- there are health factors.
You know, the kind of numbers that we're looking
at -- with Alzheimer's, diabetes, cardiovascular
and cancer -- will be our nightmare of this
century.
Alzheimer's alone, many of you know, is 604
billion, 1 percent of global GDP, and we're
confident that that number is understated
and that's today.
With risks of getting it 1-in-8 when you're
over 65 and 1-in-2 1/2 when you're over 85,
this is a 21st century nightmare, as I said.
And you look at diabetes and cancer, it's
the same thing.
So, you know, we can have all the great intentions,
we can have the right kind of programs, we
can even begin to count an aging workforce
as part of diversity, but if we don't address
the health problems, that's going to be an
issue as well.
And that's something America is particularly
well-suited to, I think, drive on the innovation
side.
I think it's probably -- rather than trying
to answer every question -- and all of three
of us, why don't we take four or five together
and then we can try to have -- so Mitzi (sp)
and then Chris (sp) and you were -- let's
say you go next, and then right there.
And then --
QUESTIONER: I actually have two questions.
I guess one is that we have a corporate desire
for efficiency, which always means getting
rid of people.
I mean, it -- I spent 13 years at IBM; I mean,
I just watched all this happen there.
The other is the opposite end of the population.
I don't know; are we talking about 20 percent,
30 percent, 40 percent of the working population
that aren't a part of these institutions where
they can go on?
I mean, it's -- some of them are the working
poor, and some of them are just the poor.
And how do we deal with them?
And I guess the last question is, I don't
want to have a lingering death, but it's illegal
for my daughter to get me pills so I could
basically bring my life to an end.
How do we deal with something like that?
Those of us that would -- I mean, I just don't
want a lingering death.
(Chuckles.)
>>HODIN (?): A good question.
Let's -- Chris, did you --
QUESTIONER: On the heels of that question,
everything seems trivial, I'm afraid.
(Laughter.)
My name is Chris Graves with Ogilvy.
And linking on from IBM, IBM learned that
while their -- surprisingly, their mainframes
did not die as predicted, the people who know
how to maintain them did.
(Laughter.)
So nobody young and cool wants to work on
them, which brings me to my question for you.
Are we so obsessed with youth culture that
there's an enormous gap in consumer products
addressing the aging?
I noticed your very cool watch -- (laughter)
-- and I wondered if that MIT AgeLab, whether
there -- you see any hope there of filling
that gap.
And is the obstacle what you alluded to earlier,
that none of us wants to admit that we reach
for the reading glasses and the ibuprofen
every day -- (laughter) -- and so we always
consider ourselves 30 years younger than we
really are, thus marketing aging products
to us is very difficult?
>>HODIN: You have to show them your glasses
-- (inaudible) --
>>MICHEL: I was just noticing that -- Mitzi
(sp) -- I just want to say, before you answer
the question, Mitzi (sp), I was just noticing
your nametag.
It's very large, "Mitzi," so you're the only
person I can name, actually -- (chuckles)
-- in the entire crowd.
And I appreciate that.
QUESTIONER: (Off mic.)
>>HODIN: Thank you, Chris.
I think -- sir, yes?
This also gives us a chance to actually pick
certain questions to answer and avoid others,
like whether you should die when you're 95
or not.
(Laughter.)
QUESTIONER: Could you please comment on the
financial support required to sustain the
two principal vehicles for supporting the
aging population in the U.S., namely Medicare
and Social Security?
Both seem to be inadequately financed at the
moment.
And this problem looks as though it will get
worse.
Do you believe that means testing is the way
to go about sustaining these support services?
Should it come out of general revenue?
Should we increase the contributions from
the working population?
How do we make them financially viable?
>>HODIN: Great question and very relevant.
Let's keep them coming.
QUESTIONER: Hi, Rob Cortel (sp) with Initelics
(sp).
I actually have a foreign policy question.
Attitudes about public policy are often experiential,
not logical.
So we have a generation that's disappearing
from World War II.
I think the last World War I vet just died
a couple days ago.
They came out of the war with a certain set
of experiences, the Marshall fund and things
like that, which led to a more internationalist
point of view, and then we had the Soviets
and all that.
As this population, the American population,
ages, it'd be interesting to -- I'd like to
understand what you are seeing in attitudes
about foreign policy and the U.S. engagement
in that, if we are in fact still the dominant
power in foreign policy.
>>HODIN: Good question.
Yes, Katherine (sp).
QUESTIONER: Thank you.
I'm interested in the potential of older adults
to solve social problems.
Often we think of late life as a roleless
phase of life where when you go to a party,
you have no answer to the question "what do
you do."
So how can we reposition aging as a real time
of contribution, where older adults are looked
at as real contributors to solving social
problems and there's an infrastructure in
place to make that easy for them to do that?
So many volunteer opportunities seem piddly,
you know, where you're licking envelopes.
They're not really tapping into your worth
as a -- and experience as a person.
>>HODIN: Zavin (ph).
>>COUGHLIN: Are you memorizing all these?
Because my brain can't hold them -- I'm writing
them down.
(Laughter.)
We're going to start answering them.
QUESTIONER: One of the issues, I think -- I
spent most of my career at the National Institute
on Aging, where we struggled with one of the
key issues, that is, the public perception
of what aging is about.
I think there needs to be a distinction between
chronological age and functional age.
The Bismarck model was based on chronological
age and didn't take into account the functional
aging.
As an example, in the late '70s the National
Institute on Aging worked with the FAA trying
to change the retirement age for pilots at
age 60, where it was automatic, without taking
into account whether a pilot could continue
functioning.
So I think that should be the -- perhaps one
of the challenges is how do we change public
policy where it's more based on a person's
ability to continue functioning well.
As longevity revolution ticks on, we're going
to see tremendous heterogeneity in the ability
of people to function.
There are many 80-year-olds that can function
quite well.
They function as well as some 40-year-olds
or 50-year-olds.
So I think that's probably a critical issue
in how we design public policies to become
more based on functional ability of a person
to continue working or to continue functioning,
whether it be with --
>>COUGHLIN: That's where technology plays
a role ---
QUESTIONER: Technology plays a role.
MR.
: -- extending the functionality.
>>HODIN: Thank you, Zavin (ph).
So why don't we start answering some of these?
Joe -- (chuckles) -- perhaps start with Zavin's
(ph) point, which I think is -- captures --
>>COUGHLIN: Yeah, I think I was going to say,
you recall a number of years ago, did a show,
old memory of baby boomers and defense policy
gone past.
The notion of technology was always considered
a force multiplier in military policy, you
know, one soldier -- good technology is five
soldiers on the field.
We're now looking at technology as fundamentally
a force multiplier for either providing care
or for providing improved performance behind
the wheel of a car, in the workplace or being
able to stay at home.
So I think functional age is incredibly important.
We will be all chronically ill.
Probably most us in this room have at least
one chronic disease, or you've been ignoring
your doctor, and you don't know that you probably
have two.
So it's not a matter of how sick you're going
to be; the question is whether you'll be ill,
but still be in the game.
To take the question about ageism, if you
will, and product development, I've got good
news and bad news in that department, the
cool watch aside.
And I couldn't find my glasses, ironically.
(Laughter.)
I had my glass case -- a number of my students
are tired of me losing my glasses; they've
put a radio frequency identification tag on
my case so that they can go on the computer
and say, Joe, your glasses are wherever I've
left them.
(Laughter.)
The good news and bad news -- and this -- I
have noticed this even in Europe, where there
had tended to be a celebration of how bald
I can be in terms of aging.
And around the world, we're starting to find
that youth culture is perhaps one of America's
greatest exports.
That said, no one wants to make or build an
old man's service or product.
And the reason for that is the following:
because a young man or a young woman will
not buy it or touch it or look at it.
But guess what?
Neither will an old man or an older woman.
And so one of the contributions of an aging
society that has got an attitude that it's
all about me and has more discretionary income
even after the downturn than any other cohort
is you are going to have a cool watch that
I'm wearing because, frankly, I can see it
without my glasses, and I can personalize
it.
I'm going to have something that's safer because
I'm frailer, but 20-year-olds don't complain
about safety.
And because I have a youthful mindset, I want
something that I can personalize, that's safe
and easy to use that all of a sudden becomes
ageless.
The notion of creating an old man's world
is neither competitive nor attractive.
And so I think one of the great contributions
will be that the next generation of old will
make a generation of better, easier-used,
more fun living experience in the future.
>>MICHEL: And I think that goes to your question,
too, Katherine (sp).
And I don't know if that's what you were asking.
But really, the -- it's already happening,
I think, to some degree.
And again, this is more taking a very positive
notation over this discussion, right?
I think that we're maybe a lot -- very focused
on the negative aspects of having this aging
population, but the fact is is that that older
American or older worker that really wants
to participate is going to be amongst their
own cohort deciding how to live out their
life.
And they're not going to be the -- I think
the notion of what an aged population means
is changing as we talk today and that there
will be other opportunities, and it's really
to the degree that they wish to continue to
be engaged.
And they won't have to just be, hopefully,
licking envelopes.
And if that's -- if that is what they want
to do, that's fine, but I don't think that
that's going to always be the case, as it
stands.
>>COUGHLIN: And I want to pick up on a theme
that Mike touched on, but I want to expand
on it based upon, you know, what are we going
to contribute as we -- as we age.
Aging is very new.
Yes, there have been older people before.
We're not the first generation of folks to
get older.
We are the first generation to grow old in
these numbers, with greater expectations -- in
fact, the big difference is an expectations
gap -- to reinvent institutions, to build
new processes and to have new roles for ourselves,
so that if we continue to believe that old
age is all about the numbers, and we take
today's policy apparatus, be it foreign or
domestic, and we simply need to make it bigger
and better for the population, then yes, we're
going to fail dismally and go bankrupt.
But if we take your question as an opportunity,
which says, I've got all this human capital
over age 50, 60, whatever you want to call
age; how do I invent new things to do, new
ways to get it done and to stay involved,
then it's a global success, not just an individual
birthday party.
>>HODIN: Well, but the other critical point
that you alluded to earlier, but did not in
that framework, is this lower fertility issue.
I mean, if we were sitting here with an extra
30 or 40 years added to life, there would
be one set of topics that one might be talking
about -- and probably wouldn't be at CFR talking
about it, frankly -- and one of the core topics
would be around what do I do when I'm 94 and,
you know, lying there and want to -- whatever
you want to have happen to yourself --
QUESTIONER: (I'd call for an ?) end.
>>HODIN: Called to an end --
>>COUGHLIN: She doesn't want to linger.
(Laughter.)
>>HODIN: -- you know, that would be one set
of discussions.
Because of the low fertility that is stunningly
impactful around the world, in country after
country after country, you have this profound
shift that make the institutional arrangements
of the 20th century fiscally unsustainable.
Which gets to the point that the gentleman
asked about, you know, Medicare and Social
Security, or one can ask about the national
health scheme in the U.K., or Greece, or any
number of places where underlying the basic
point is that when there are fewer people
working to support a larger number of people
who are traditionally retired, the numbers
just don't work.
So one answer, I would suggest, is that you
have people active and working, in various
ways of redefining work, longer and perhaps
much longer.
And if we define, as the Europeans are claiming
to articulate it, a healthy and active aging,
then you can actually achieve this.
You know, getting from here to there is not
easy, but that's why this is the kind of topic
that we're attempting to address here.
So you know, my answer to your question, to
go directly, you know, no, the answer is,
we -- and there's some, again, in the audience
who are more familiar with this than I am
and more expert -- we can fiddle with Social
Security, as we are doing, and as happens,
that can find at least openings for solutions
with respect to when we pay, how much we pay,
how we do it.
Medicare is different matter.
If we -- again, you look at the five or six
-- what's now in the term of art being used
is noncommunicable diseases -- you know, we
had that U.N. outcomes last year -- diabetes,
cancer, Alzheimer's.
You know, if those numbers continue the way
they are today -- and so this just is fiscally
unsustainable.
So the question is, how do we spend on finding
-- for prevention and actual solutions versus
care?
I mean, this is a huge debate that we're -- we
must step up to.
But you know, as a friend of mine looked at
a picture in the '50s of people in iron lungs,
with polio, you know, how many of those could
you have warehoused, to be very blunt, you
know, had we not had the Salk vaccine?
Well, again, the same thing with Alzheimer's.
We can care for people and be as wonderful
as we want to be, but if we don't find the
way to cure it and ultimately to prevent it,
it's just not going to be manageable fiscally.
So what I'm suggesting is that aging populations
and components of it are really economic policy.
It's not about how do we take care of 90-year-olds,
even though it will get us there.
It's about how do we find economic growth
and how do we manage today's fiscal sustainability
challenges?
>>COUGHLIN: And part of the policy's also
about personal responsibility as well and
what level does one begin to treat themselves
well in their 30s so that they live well in
their 40s and so on.
If you go through life, as I did growing up
in Philly, believing that cheese steaks, Tastykakes
and scrapple are food groups -- (laughter)
-- I'm not sure I have the right to ask any
of you, when I am 67 years old and hypertensive,
diabetic and God knows what else, to, say,
flip the bill.
And -- but we have to have that phased discussion
on what is that new social contract.
>>MICHEL: Yeah, I --
>>HODIN: We have maybe one or two other questions.
Just to -- yes.
Go ahead.
It's all right.
Jump in.
>>MICHEL: OK.
QUESTIONER: Thanks.
Alessandro Pio from Asian Development Bank.
If you compare the United States to other
countries, even with all the optimistic -- and
I think they are good points -- assumptions
about longer life and longer work life and
so forth, one of the key differences is the
savings rate.
I mean, you will still have to finance some
of these health expenditures, some of these
living expenditures as a share of your income
is lower compared to your expenses.
And in the United States you quibble about,
well, the savings rate is 4 percent or 5 percent,
and the impact that has on the recovery, whereas
both Europe and Asian countries have saving
rates in the order of 20, 30 percent.
That does imply -- of course have an impact,
then, on what you can reinvest through insurance
and other financial mechanisms that allow
you to pay for these things.
So I think there is very basic questions about
consumption versus savings.
And the consumption model that you have, you
go to a store, you cannot buy one screwdriver;
you have to buy packs of six.
You don't really need to do that if you only
need one.
So I think there is some thinking about the
consumption and savings model that needs to
be considered.
I don't know what your views are on that.
>>MICHEL: I think they should start manufacturing
screws that have different sizes.
That would solve that.
(Laughter.)
But -- I'm sorry.
But your point is good one, because we do
have to -- we do have to save more.
And I'll tell you, policy should think about
this, because -- I'll give you a great example.
We -- in the financial services market we're
using or looking a lot at behavioral finance
and how people make decisions about their
savings.
And there was a very successful exercise that
was put in place for auto and -- autoenrollment
into your retirement plan, auto-escalation
ideas.
And while I think that's a really excellent
example of some things that we can do to help
increase, we also have to be really thoughtful
around the "set it and forget it" mentality,
which I think is very problematic to savings.
Understanding savings takes a lot of time.
There is not a financial community that is
prepared or equipped really to support the
education that's necessary.
If you -- just think about your own work experience.
And I can't speak for what it's like to work
for government, but just think about your
own personal experience, how many times someone's
offered you financial education that was not
personally sought out for yourself.
It's hard to get that.
And you don't learn it in an hour.
In fact, the amount of people who've told
me that the most they've ever learned about
saving in their life for anything, whether
it's children's education, buying a home,
retirement, they learned in their 401(k) enrollment
meeting.
That's a -- that's a very problematic testimony
to our commitment to helping people understand
how to get there and how to save, how to balance
the choices that need to be made between saving
for college for their children, putting a
down payment on a home and saving for retirement.
You talk to a 30-year-old, they have completely
different savings challenges than somebody
who's 20 or somebody who's 40 or somebody
who's 50.
And we have to help people learn how to do
that better, and maybe things like behavioral
finance will help us understand how to do
that better, in a more efficient way.
But right now policy -- we should be thinking
about how to drive policy to help employers,
which, in -- at least in the United States,
is the primary delivery system for retirement
or savings products, in a more efficient way,
because right now we really don't have an
infrastructure to support education on a broad
basis, to help people understand how to do
it.
I don't know if you have --
>>HODIN: Thank you.
Hazel.
QUESTIONER: Hazel Denton, Georgetown University.
I wanted to pick up the point about the savings
rate and also the independence that we should
have, the self-care we should have.
Whenever I go back home to England, I ask
my young relatives -- these are people in
their 20s -- what in your pension plan?
And every one of them has a good answer.
Britain is moving away from these lifetime
employment situations to short-term contract
work.
That's something I see beginning to come in
here and surely is going to be one way in
which it's going to be a lot easier to hire
the older people.
We just have to get away from the idea that
anyone over 65 falls in the box of elderly.
I think this audience will agree.
(Laughter.)
>>HODIN: Absolutely.
QUESTIONER: Can I -- one more?
>>HODIN: We have -- we have about two more
minutes.
So maybe one more question.
QUESTIONER: She passed it to me.
I'm Arbra Johnson (sp) with Itochio (sp).
And I'm hoping you can speak to the fact that
it's not just retirement that's getting later.
It's having kids, buying houses, paying for
college.
So how does everything have to shift?
I mean, I'm 40.
My youngest is 2, and I'm not atypical, at
least in the Washington region.
>>COUGHLIN: No.
Over a half million women every year have
their first child after age 41 in the United
States alone.
In Europe they're not having children, pretty
much period.
In Germany there was a headline on their newspaper
that was a -- celebrating a year ago that
they had 600 more kids that year than they
did the year before.
So no, things are shifting and things are
elongating -- multiple careers, cycling in
and out.
So really longevity's rewriting all the things
that we took for granted.
>>MICHEL: But you know, I'm -- I have a -- I
had my child at -- one child -- I'm so statistically
on point with whatever you're talking about
here --
MR.
: Yeah.
>>MICHEL: -- thirty-seven years old when I
had my child.
And the idea of sustaining a career -- and
for many women particularly, if we're going
to talk about women and retirement -- has
a lot to do with when to have that child relative
to your career advancement.
And for women in their 30s, those decisions
become very defining on whether you continue
a career or you continue with a job.
And so I think there's a very important nuance
to that decision, whether it's a career or
whether it's a job.
And as our -- as our discussion will probably
end here shortly, it's really important, I
think, to understand and to be very thoughtful
about what we want our society to be doing.
Do we want to develop careers, or do we want
to develop just a job where you come in and
you come out, but you have some sort of social
network beyond that that's going to help sustain
you?
Because that's a hard thing particularly for
women to be able to do.
But that saving rate should be -- the concept
of that has to start much younger for women
or men, I think.
>>HODIN: So maybe we'll conclude on two points.
One is related to this, and that is when you
look at the work that is being prepared at
the World Health Organization or that was
discussed in Moscow last week inside APEC
on the topic of aging populations -- World
Health Organization's preparation for their
celebration of aging at World Health Day,
which is the first week in April -- they're
focused on healthy lifestyles.
And it's a -- it's not about 93-year-olds
living or not; it's about healthy lifestyles.
And I think, as Joe and Kelly said, what this
shift in demographics is doing to us, the
longevity on the one hand, the lower fertility
on the other, is transforming how we live
and what kind of institutions, both private
and public, are aligned to that, are fit for
purpose.
Let me conclude with a concluding comment
that Undersecretary Hormats certainly wrote
yesterday and might have said if he were here:
"Working together, we can turn the longevity
bequeathed us from the 20th century into a
positive driver of growth, contribution and
economic activity into the 21st."
Some of you may know there was a book that
was launched at Davos about a week and a half
ago now -- that's two weeks ago -- titled
"Global Population Aging: Peril or Promise?"
You know, I vote for the promise side, but
there's a lot of space between here and there,
and I think that's what the undersecretary
was saying, and that's what we're all saying,
that we have the opportunity to do this, but
it's a matter of stepping up to the policy.
We were talking beforehand that one looks
for examples in history.
And you don't have to go back that far to
think of some major issues that have been
picked up as very profound policy challenges
with institutions to accompany them, the environment
being one example.
You know, pre roughly 1970, that as an issue
didn't exist, let alone -- let alone, for
better and worse, having institutions around
it.
Well, you know, perhaps the 21st century is
suggesting that around this aging populations,
we need a similar kind of framework.
So thank you all for coming.
We will continue these round tables and discussions
and appreciate your attention.